éboue dit toute la vérité les chéris par
exemple pendant cinq minutes et sans
filtre on va rappeler le problème
mercredi tf1 programmé 1 50 minutes
inside consacré à la disparition de
jovialité problème l'émission était
enregistrée avant son décès et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de téléspectateurs ont
été choqués on voulait vous montrer un
bout de l'émission ils ont parlé de
johnny au passé alors que le copyright
de l'émission indique novembre 2010 est
donc avant son décès il ya plein de gens
sur twitter ça a été un bep faire le
mans totalement déshumanisé incroyable
ce 50 minutes inside
car enregistré des plombes avant la mort
de johnny c'est gênant je trouve ça
indécent de la part de tf1 de diffuser
des reportages préenregistré sur la mort
de johnny trop gros trop glauque ce
syncopated fight sur la mort de johnny
bon il ya eu il ya eu vraiment une tonne
de tweets là dessus on va en parler
pendant cinq minutes
regardez juste l'image alors évidemment
cette semaine 50 minutes inside
bouleverse ses programmes pour une
émission spéciale en hommage à johnny
hallyday c'est toute la france qui est
bouleversé à 74 ans celui qui restera
pour toujours l'idole des jeunes sont
étalés il laisse une famille endeuillée
des millions de fans éplorés
c'est notre façon à nous de lui rendre
hommage ce soir est la meilleure façon
de le saluer c'est d'écouter en musique
alors les cherry qui trouvent que tf1 et
l'émission 50 minutes inside a manqué de
respect à johnny parce que c'est ce qui
ressortait sur les réseaux sociaux cinq
minutes c'est parti jean michel bérard
oui bientôt bien sûr et n'importe quoi
ils n'ont mais il ya deux choses
différentes
on me dit oui ou non je trouve ça
scandaleux mais pas tous c'est la
présentation des de nikos aliagas et
sandrine quétier qui est scandaleux
c'est que ça vous pouvez le très bien le
faire en direct le jour des événements
du bol j'ai enregistré convoque les
reportages tout le monde le fait c'est
tout j'ai travaillé dans la presse
écrite
on appelle ça malheureusement ces dames
ont mal choisi alors moi le mot que je
retiens de tout ce que vous avez dit
c'est j'ai travaillé dans la presse
écrite dans la presse écrite le mot est
terrible ça s'appelle le frigo sert tous
les papiers qu'on fait parce qu'on sait
quelqu'un batma pagnac mabri on appelle
ça on prépare mes papiers du reportage
donc que les chaînes de télévision ne
veuille pas et priaulx ne veuille pas
est prise au dépourvu et préparent des
magazines normal mais pas la
présentation aux puces ils ont fui les
atouts il propose aux gens de parler de
johnny au passé l'innovation demandé de
johnny parle ou par exemple je suis un
peu d'accord avec lui pour une fois ah
c'est vrai que c'est choquant c'est
hyper chaud quand comment ça fait
plaisir d'entendre quelqu'un qui parle
distinctement
merci bien merci oui tu as tu entends ce
que je te tue pas plus alors vous êtes
d'accord avec lui oui je suis d'accord
avec lui je trouve ça hyper choquant
enfin même si on aime beaucoup
nikos pression on adore nous c'est un
gars très très bien les deux mais oui
mais oui c'est choquant parce qu'ils
prennent même des têtes de circonstance
alors que l'événement n'a pas eu lieu
donc c'est alors c'est vrai que c'est
dur à faire et si tellement d'accord
avec elie semoun tout le monde est
d'accord avec nos deux d'accord mais
c'est tellement choquant déjà le 50
minutes inside qui est totalement
déprogrammée pour trois semaines alors
que c'est une émission de week end ils
sont en habit de deuil
ils ont l'air désolé il parle de johnny
au passé simple et enregistre en
novembre ceci dit moi j'ai déjà fait un
reportage sur ta mort 1
à tous les copains j'ai tout fait des
témoignages c'est comme ça c'est fait mr
des terribles de points alors est-ce que
ce qu'ils ont manqué en espagne ou par
oui ou non
oui et de manquer de respect sur les
plateaux de lancement un premier qui
était enregistré en juin un deuxième en
septembre et peut-être plus récemment
donc c'était un peu précipité s'il ya
plein lancement juste le documentaire en
soit c'est passé comme une lettre à la
poste
d'accord bernard muna extrêmement
choquant évidemment des douanes les
animateurs on le redit parce qu'ils sont
sympas et qu'on leur a demandé de le
faire en revanche ces gens à témoin le
respect à johnny manque de respect à la
fin mois il ya oui c'est choquant
benjamin est remonté je vous donnais les
coulisses de ces émissions là qui sont
enregistrés le jeudi ou le ils font
toujours c'est un principe un plateau
qui s'appelle le plateau aux morts où
ils disent et on commence par cette
triste nouvelle
au cas où il y aurait quelqu'un de connu
qui meurent entre l'orchestré ils le
font toujours toujours la main chaude a
passé un principe ça c'est leur lait bon
d'accord la pétanque et les charges
maintenant honnêtement et ça m'étonne de
nikos qu'on puisse faire un plateau en
plus c'est son pote en disant 'je
oniemba dit honnêtement c'est un foutage
de gueule c'est ce que rob et moi je
vous le dire - demandé de faire ça je
n'aurais pas fait j'aurais refusé
ils peuvent très bien ici on dirait
merde il ya des tas de gens qui sont qui
sont mobilisés y aller les rédactions
était sur le bleu le pont guerre à 4
heures du matin tu appelles tu dis coup
de déco ce machin tu prends ton costume
et une faute en plateau
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de faire ça
vous rendez compte allez dire que
quelqu'un est mort il est alors qu'il
est la même c'est du délire je suis
d'accord mais j'ai refusé par comprendre
voulons vous au nom du parti m'ont
demandé de participer j'ai refusé des
participants avaient alors malik non
mais je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
benjamin benjamin c'est vraiment là
c'était de l'attendre quoi en fait c'est
un coup de com on attend que monsieur
décède et au final c'est comme ça fait
mal parce que je me dis que c'est
vraiment de la programmation du début à
la fin faire jouer les gens en plus
faire jouer des têtes de
et nikos mine de rien et mais qu on leur
demande de faire un truc ils vont dire
quoi tf1 veut dire non le fait pareil
dix jours ça n'a rien fait de coûts
fixes et se débrouillent c'est un
événement national tout le monde en a
parlé du fronton taxi tu mets ton
costume et tu fais attention à toi aussi
en situation et tu seras bien meilleure
est-ce que tu sera effectivement peiné
là c'était ni fait ni à faire
oui mais pas s'imaginer que johnny et
appris par une indiscrétion y avait des
genres j'y serai un plateau pour dire
annoncé qu'il était mort c'est vrai baba
on découvre pas quand même aujourd'hui
le cynisme de la télévision ou des
médias
nous ici même pendant une semaine on
nous a dit peut-être que johnny va
mourir et on nous a dit qu'elle une
chanson vous préférez de doni qu'elle
par ce parti ou car fait de l'avoir en
plein direct ça on va dire on va réagir
à chaud oui j'avais telle chanson sert
n'a rien à voir on s'est préparés pas
finir bientôt enregistrer la bonne et
qu'il pouvait mourir
jonathan question pensons à nantes
d'abord
et à dix secondes donc du coup moi ce
que je disais c'est horrible de spéculer
sur la mort de quelqu'un et d'attendre
leurs tarifs pour juste diffuser quelque
chose je trouve ça horrible alors voilà
c'est vrai qu'alors on va regarder la
réaction et il a dit oui voilà à
tellement bons qu'ils sont assez
d'accord avec vous